♪♪
-Now let's get to the news.
Russian President Vladimir Putin
is reportedly expected
to formally declare war
this week on Ukraine.
Really? Now?
Putin's like the guy
who's been dating the same woman
for six months
but refuses to say girlfriend.
Ukraine has its own dresser,
drawer in your apartment.
You're at war.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden last week
named Karine Jean-Pierre
as the next White House
press secretary,
which makes her
the first Black woman
and openly gay person
to hold the position.
So she's going to spend a lot
of time at the podium saying,
no, I mean,
questions about world events.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration issued
a warning over the weekend
that the country may see 100
million coronavirus infections
this fall and winter
unless we, as a nation,
commit to going out and
catching it this summer instead.
[ Laughter ]
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
said in a new interview
that the Supreme Court
overturning Roe versus Wade
could pave the way
for a national ban on abortion.
On the bright side, Mexico
might finally pay for a wall.
[ Laughter ]
At a rally held by former
President Trump last week,
Pennsylvania Republican Senate
candidate Dr. Mehmet Oz
was repeatedly booed
by the crowd.
In his defense, that's just how
Pennsylvania says hello.
[ Laughter ]
The CDC announced
over the weekend
that it's investigating
a recent coronavirus outbreak
on a Carnival cruise ship.
That might be the shortest
investigation ever conducted.
It's a cruise ship, you say?
Well, I think we've figured
out your problem.
[ Laughter ]
U2's Bono and The Edge held
a surprise concert yesterday
at a subway station in Ukraine.
If you're curious how it went,
check your iTunes.
It's already in there.
[ Laughter ]
They probably didn't think
that decision
would have
such a long tail.
Is that a decade?
It's like a decade ago now.
What's the worst
that can happen?
They're still making jokes
about it 10 years from now.
What a good Bono.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good Bono.
I feel like you roll your eyes
at me, Wally.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a family
in Massachusetts
recently rescued a puppy
that they found
on the side of the road,
which was actually
a baby coyote.
Said the family,
I guess it's for the best.
It didn't get along
with our cat anyway.
[ Laughter ]
Thanks to the family
who posed for that photo.
♪♪
President Biden today
held a bilateral meeting
with Italian
Prime Minister Mario Draghi
to reaffirm the partnership
between the two countries.
Though I think he misunderstood
which partnership.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden has reportedly
told his national
security officials
that recent press leaks
about intelligence sharing
with Ukraine need to stop
and could further
inflame tensions with Russia.
So remember, the Ukrainian
people have our full support,
but if anyone asks,
no, they don't.
Congressional Republicans
are reportedly split over
what to do if the Supreme Court
officially overturns
Roe versus Wade.
Apparently, they can't decide
between a ticker tape parade
or a dance party.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's a very fair point,
but I understand why
it was a huge bummer.
[ Laughter ]
The Senate passed a bill
yesterday to expand security
for Supreme Court justices,
and just in time.
Did you see how close that
lunatic got to Clarence Thomas?
[ Laughter ]
150 personal items
that belonged to the late
Supreme Court Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg
recently sold in an auction
for over $800,000,
though I think some of
Kavanaugh's stuff got mixed in.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Texas
are looking for a man
who allegedly burglarized a home
and then mowed the front
and back lawns
before fleeing the scene.
Police describe
the suspect as your dad.
[ Laughter ]
A dog that escaped from a yard
in Brooklyn over a week ago
was spotted swimming
in the East River
and then walking through
the Battery Tunnel
before he was rescued
from the parking lot
of a Home Depot in New Jersey.
Though I'm not sure rescued
is the right word.
It sounds more like
he was apprehended.
[ Laughter ]
Who told you
where to find me?
Authorities in Nevada
have reported finding
several sets of human remains
over the last week
in Lake Mead as water levels
drop amid an ongoing drought.
On the upside, the Mafia
is now very invested
in stopping climate change.
[ Laughter ]
Artist Andy Warhol
silkscreen portrait
of Marilyn Monroe sold yesterday
at auction for $195 million
and at Old Navy for $6.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Starbucks added
a new drink to its menu today,
which is cold brew coffee
topped with chocolate foam
and sweetened
with vanilla syrup.
It's also their first drink
to come with the bathroom key.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke today
in Illinois
about his administration's
plan to support farmers.
Although I feel like
he should be asking
about their plan to support him.
Do you guys got one of those
"Charlotte's Web" spiders
that could write
something nice about me?
[ Laughter ]
Well, speaking yesterday
at the White House
about the steps
he's taking to curb inflation,
President Biden acknowledged
the Democrats
"control all three branches
of the government."
Oh, so you are aware?
It's like hearing
a six-year-old say
Genesis was better
with Peter Gabriel.
Definitely.
We just didn't know you knew.
Bill Gates announced yesterday
that he has tested positive
for a breakthrough case
of the coronavirus.
Gates says
he probably got the virus
because he forgot
to install McAfee.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Bill Gates has
tested positive for coronavirus.
So for now, he's just going
to attend meetings on Zoom.
Oh, I mean, Microsoft Teams!
We all -- we love
Microsoft Teams, everybody.
A House intelligence
subcommittee is set next week
to hold the first open
congressional hearing on UFOs.
Oh, come on.
How many times are you going
to make him testify?
[ Laughter ]
According to newly
released audio
from an interview
after the Capitol attack,
Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham praised
President Biden
and said he's the
"best person to have in office."
And then today he said,
"I'm going to let
that go to voicemail."
[ Laughter ]
Actor James Cromwell
super glued himself
to the counter
of a Starbucks in New York
yesterday
to protest the chain
charging more
for plant-based milks.
While over a Dunkin',
You kind of just stick
to the counter naturally.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you very much.
Two unoccupied beach houses
in North Carolina
recently fell into the ocean,
or, as the realtor put it,
360-degree ocean views.
[ Laughter ]
A rat ran on to the field
during last night's
New York Mets game.
A staff member
quickly caught it,
and out of habit, tossed it
to a kid in the front row.
[ Laughter ]
Hi, Baseball rat.
I got a baseball rat.
And finally, an alligator
was recently spotted
in the drive through
of a fast food
restaurant in North Carolina.
But this is annoying.
He had no idea what he wanted.
Let's go!
You're holding up the line!
In his new book,
Ex-Defense Secretary
Mark Esper writes that
despite his hatred
of press leaks,
former President Trump
was "the biggest leaker of all."
Said Trump,
"Well, that's the last time
I show him
the Area 51 aliens.
Oh, damn it."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden criticized
Republicans at a fundraiser
last night
for their recent
attacks on Disney
and said "they're going to storm
Cinderella's castle
before this is over."
Oh, buddy, I hate to tell you.
If they're storming anything,
it's the Hall of Presidents.
Also, that's me, right?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, imagine finding --
That's how I found out
I was a president.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden told a small
gathering at a Democratic
fundraiser last night
that it's going to be hard
to maintain the majority
in both houses of Congress,
especially since
they don't have it
in the first place.
Arizona Senator
Kyrsten Sinema
appeared on the Senate
floor yesterday
wearing a pink tie-dyed shirt
that said "no thanks."
I don't know what that means
except that Arizona
elected a senator
who only shops at airports.
[ Laughter ]
Even weirder,
Bernie Sanders was wearing this.
[ Laughter ]
I need it. I don't know
what to tell you.
I need it.
I'm not going to apologize.
Mama needs wine.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today called
Ferdinand Marcos Jr.
to congratulate him
on winning
the Philippine
presidential election.
Said Biden, "Remember,
winning is the easy part.
The hard part
is convincing everybody
that you actually won."
[ Laughter ]
While speaking yesterday,
the thousands of union
electrical workers,
President Biden referred
to former President Trump
as "the great MAGA king."
Okay, can we please
not give him any more ideas?
[ Laughter ]
North Korea reported its
first coronavirus outbreak today
and ordered all cities and
counties to enter a lockdown,
or as they call it,
business as usual.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
said on Tuesday
that his official residence,
Gracie Mansion, is haunted
and added
"I don't care what anyone says.
There are ghosts in there."
Mm, I don't think that's
who's booing you.
According to a new study,
the top three baby names
that are set to make
a comeback this year are
Joan, Mary and Margaret,
which is also a full curse
in a Catholic household.
Oh, Joan, Mary and Margaret!
[ Laughter ]
In fact...
I stubbed me toe!
[ Laughter ]
So, Bill, I've got a little bit
of criticism
recently about my
really good Irish accent.
And finally, the New York State
Lottery announced yesterday
that the results
of Tuesday's drawing
were published with the wrong
mega ball number,
and things are pretty
awkward at the house
that thought they won.
Honey, I was joking
about the divorce.
That was ha-ha, it's me.
That's when I'm funny.
That was a monologue,
everybody.
♪♪